(audience cheers)
Whoo.
'Cause I'll tell you anything
or I'll do anything.
And we have John here, hi John.
Hi Drew.
I'm so happy to do this with you.
Thank you, I'm happy to be here, thanks for having me.
All right, what's it gonna be Drewth or dare?
I'm gonna go with the Drewth.
You can't handle the Drewth.
(audience laughs)
I've never done that before.
(John laughs)
All right, what's it gonna be?
Okay, so my question is,
is it ever a good idea to lie?
My significant other who's absent, he paints.
And sometimes he asks me if,
you know, his paintings are to my liking
and the honest truth is,
you know, sometimes they're not to my taste.
Sometimes I think they could be a little better.
But my question overall is,
is it ever a good idea to lie?
You know, to keep from hurting someone's feelings.
I hear you.
I'm gonna say no,
but I really do like that saying,
"It's not what you say.
It's how you say it,"
because I also think there's a benefit to being like,
"I like it, but like, it's not my favorite,
but I see what you're doing.
Why don't you take me through the process?"
Right.
I think just to know
and pushing that person away is kind of cold.
Right, right.
Maybe you can say like,
"I'm still trying to kind of get it.
Why don't you explain it to me?"
Here's why I love not lying.
First of all, don't lie.
Don't have secrets.
They kind of go in the same family to me,
but when someone really does like something,
it's so exciting
because you know they haven't BSed you the whole time.
True.
And you can actually gauge
when something is genuine versus not.
Right.
So I don't think
that it's worth it to be fraudulent ever,
but I don't think that ever has to come with cruelty,
insensitivity or be short and curt.
There is a way we can tell our truth
that is kind, empathic, sensitive, and a little patient.
Right, right.
Thank you so much, Drew.
I appreciate you.
(audience applauds)
And then when you do love something,
it's just such a win.
Right.
And so exciting, you know?
Believe me, I have kids and they show me all their art
and like all their stuff.
And sometimes I'm just like,
I don't want to tell them I love everything.
Like what's that gonna do for them?
Right.
I'm not harsh or critical,
but you know.
I think just gentleness and honesty
can go beautifully hand in hand.
All right, thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Good luck.
(upbeat outro music)